yeah oh my god I'm so sorry boys what is
going on bro what did you do oh honey
looks like Rambo like hi I'm Shawn I'm
cute I'm Blake we are single guys and
today we are trying to recreate Kylie
Jenner's makeup routine are you feeling
confident how are you feeling
so I mean who's getting the makeup are
we all I do not think it takes 15
minutes you got me tutorials I watched
how many one and I feel like I'm a pro
at this point you ready to get started
I mean you won't hit play okay so I'm
gonna go from here to here it's a light
color you're still looking for the
concealer I found it bro oh my god what
is this wall what is this right is this
right put some more on there put some
more in there and then we got up you got
to get the blotter so what okay
we're blotchy wait I feel like they gave
us that water for a reason
no we don't have to walk no we don't
need the water yes what is it okay
amazing don't close your eyes so much
what flavor is that way hood on we got a
star square wait what let's put the
foundation on his face
oh wait doesn't look that bad I'm
honestly thirsty
it was good tasty wait I want you shoot
your forehead
sheesh Shawn can you stop we do need
your face perfect one darling hey
where's that blender blended I mean I
got it
[Music]
I mean single guys yeah we need some
right here from here from here you're
gonna take it over plank does it look oh
dude you look great you look fantastic
yeah yeah wait where am I getting powder
from
I think that's the powder okay Sean you
are not doing the makeup you are
throwing me off bro oh dude is it look
good or no it looks fantastic
I mean I feel like we're not doing that
we're not doing horrible I don't think
so oh wait bronzer
start from the ear so from the ear to
the mic the lip yeah well first I'm
working oh do its forehead too so go
from the top of the forehead to the ear
into the crevice of the lip
that's how Kylie Jo what you got this
one what are you so worried man honestly
your man dime right now bro yep and I'm
broke still one to ten you would die
yeah Oh lipliner all right you want me
to do this also make them get an extra
little lip on top from here oh she's a
bit over the whole lip hmm
so she puts over yeah just rub it in all
right
and now and now we're gonna we're gonna
clean this up we know it's ugly that's
what the wet works
look we messed up but we're gonna fix it
cuz he's up here baisha yeah I feel like
everything was going
relatively okay wasn't good it's like
really bad oh okay blush how do you get
it off you know oh my god I'm so sorry
what is going on his eyebrow what did
you do oh he looks like Rambo wait
there's lashes no we're not doing
eyelashes today no we're doing the
lashes closer okay no you gotta keep
your eyes sterile okay okay you're doing
a weird freak out thing with your eyes I
think you roll up
I do not wait are you doing Wayne oh he
needs his eyes open huh you got to look
up bro yeah hold your hair just let me
open my eyes oh we're trying to do two
things at once man look up to the sky
there we go
look at his blinken's dude you got to
stop blinking yeah we didn't know we
didn't put lip gloss it's covered and
she put it on doesn't make any sense
gloss those lips I can do this
alright let's get it I think we did it
this is wet thing last thing she does is
this spray oh wait do you wanna just do
it
I got you I got finish it all finish it
off close your eyes Sean girl let me
spray something in his face I've got to
take advantage yeah let's talk about
this
alright listen yeah let's give you like
a real what they know here that's not
bad
wait let's just use this mirrors closer
hey what do you think of Sean I think
he's a shame that people think he looks
good real quick can you guys guess which
celebrity would you say wait I will get
Carly cuz of the lip Harry Jenner
yeah
if they're not one more time it's what
ya know like it's so subtle act it's
actually so subtle do you think this is
subtle wheel yeah you're gonna go into
beautycon that's a thing yeah yeah the
thing just go get straight doesn't mean
I'm gonna say outside of the lips I
think we did pretty good
honestly I think that you messed it we
shouldn't have let him do the lip gloss
or attack where it always we're talking
in here talking through the hole oh you
had to do was sit here you want to do
the next one
yeah you ready no you ready no dude man
I'm over here is Amanda
[Music]